Rusia se ha mostrado hoy dispuesta a
permitir que el acuerdo por el cereal
ucraniano que se llegó en Estambul en
julio del año pasado pueda continuar por
los próximos meses
un acuerdo que tiene que renovarse cada
120 días y que Rusia amenazó con romper
la última vez que se tenía que renovar
el pasado noviembre el viceministro de
asuntos exteriores rusos ser gay
verosímil se ha reunido hoy en Ginebra
con representantes de Naciones Unidas
que fueron los que mediaron para llegar
a ese acuerdo entre
Moscú y kiev con también la ayuda de
Turquía ha dicho bershinning que Rusia
aceptaría la prolongación de este
acuerdo No no por 120 días que es lo que
ha sido hasta ahora sino por 60 y ha
puesto también más condiciones Rusia
quiere sobre todo que este acuerdo
también incluya la exportación de tanto
fertilizantes como productos agrícolas
rusas que no son exportados por Rusia no
porque Europa y Estados Unidos hayan
sancionado estas estos sectores rusos
que no lo han hecho sino porque muchas
empresas transnacionales y muchas
aseguradoras temen comercializar con
estos productos rusos por el temor de
que puedan ser sancionados
secundariamente por Estados Unidos y por
la Unión Europea el plazo para esta
renovación que aún no se ha poblado
Aunque Rusia acepte hacerlo en los
próximos días tiene que ser hasta el
próximo sábado 18 de marzo es el tiempo
por el cual se tiene que renovar este
acuerdo si Rusia mantiene su veto como
ya amenazado en el pasado o si lo
levanta se permitirá que el trigo y el
cereal ucraniano que ha estado saliendo
desde Ucrania desde julio pueda seguir
haciéndolo a pesar de la guerra en
Ucrania